Hey youtubes, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Walking Dead Mid Season Finale video.
Someday this pain will be useful to you. So
just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet. Because they actually did
some big comic book stuff. If there's anything
I feel like people are gonna walk away being
upset by though is is all the comic book stuff
that they did not do because we are in the
middle of no way out just in terms of comic
book storylines in it did not in the way that
no way out ended hold out hope that you want
though they could totally push the ending
of no way out like some of the things some
of the debts that end up happening into the
second half of the season just a quick reminder
there is a new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's a $20
Amazon gift card just because there were so
many clear WTF things in this episode, I'm
doing top 10 this time starting with Sam cannot
close his mouth as they proceed through the
tulips or the walkers have you want to think
about it I totally loved that song was playing
in the background so creepy the opening scene
was Sam right there that's exactly why you
don't let children take food to the room even
though Ron seems like he's the weak point
in the group right now I think that Sam is
the weakest link he is probably going to track
progress them seriously just try to get his
mom's attention on the number nine though
Ron goes after Carl with the gun my mom my
brother my dad they're all dead you're dead
to when people were talking about this going
down before the episode there were like two
things happening you like one what was wrong
going to do like was you neglect or Carl or
wasn't he into what was going to happen during
their encounter if you want to talk about
Carl from the comics be sure to use spoiler
tag's because the whole encounter is very
different from what happens in the comics
the only thing I was pretty sure about was
like the second part like what would not be
happening to Carl as a result of this encounter
I think that's the only way I can say without
actually doing spoilers for the comic the
show is completely sidestepped a big thing
with Rick's character like a big twist of
his character so I kind of expected the same
treatment with Carl's character but I definitely
think the Carl's giving Ron way too much credit
like he lies to Jessie and Rick about what
happened in the garage we're trying to get
tools WTF dude the kids gonna keep coming
after you might as well sell them out nine
is that Sam is the weakest link in the group
right now but just look at Ron he's already
kind of been Walker mode any way he looks
like he is Apsley ready to commit Walker assisted
suicide it any moment on the number eight
Maggie gets stuck on top of the platform and
they did not resolve it a lever of top there
Glenn sees her with Enid we have to wait till
the second half of season to find out what
happens to her she's pregnant read between
the lines she's definitely not can a dive
she's she's totally safe the neck and a killer
with a baby in her stomach if they're going
to do that they would wait so she was super
pregnant that's actually good polo take do
you think that The Walking Dead would ever
have the quota quote guts to kill a pregnant
woman especially a main character who was
pregnant even though the show airs on cable
and it's a super bloodied comic I just I feel
like that's something they would never do
I know they killed Laurie but they didn't
kill her till after she had baby Judith and
for those of you asking about baby Judith
she got put underneath one of those Walker
tarps that they were wearing the Rick's holding
her underneath the guts of it and accept to
put guts on the baby's face can you imagine
them on said organ at the put some Walker
guts on your baby's face ma'am I can't even
begin to imagine a stage mom that would let
them do that to their baby onto my number
seven WTF Deanna gets bitten and is definitely
going to die the wound is so grievous there's
no question about it she's definitely get
to die by the end of the episode but Michelle
knows about her plan that she was riding on
that map and they're going to try and execute
is a way to deal with the super horde but
Deanna gets that moment with each of the characters
like Bob got last season where she imparts
wisdom as she goes out like she tells Rick
you are the best man for the job I didn't
save you because your good father or because
you can grow the best damn beard ever as a
B because of the right man for the job rent
the tail end of November so who misses Rick's
beard by the way it was getting pretty crazy
by the time they found the save zone last
year onto my number six WTF Denise gets trapped
with the crazy wolf that Morgan is keeping
prisoner you know who he reminds me of when
he's giving her that crazy philosophy speech
it's the Joker like the Joker is a very learned
person is very smart very intelligent but
he just has the craziest ideas so he will
twist your mind which is exactly what the
walls are like their budget twisted human
beings really the tension is is that she's
going to help them like show me your wound
in the he's gonna go after her when she does
for the real WTF doesn't come till later tell
Carol barrels downstairs sidebar to Rick explaining
his plan to everyone in the house though for
going to cover ourselves in these guts don't
worry I've done this before he actually had
she did do that in previous seasons just like
covered himself with Walker beds and we see
michonne we sing a bunch of characters do
this technically it's called Walker camo there's
also a group in the comics called the whispers
that wear face masks they were dead people
skin so that also works to it so much fun
just watching the characters react like Jessie
Gabriel apparently not big cosplayers do you
want to cosplayers The Walking Dead apparently
they never did The Walking Dead experience
a, for was a little disappointed that he didn't
throw up with an Sam walks in and it looks
like he's already proved his pants when Jesse
tells him what they're going to do just pretend
you're brave just fake it till you make it
onto my number three WTF Deanna goes down
fighting so she's going to commit suicide
due to the noble thing like give me the got
all to myself but that she hears the walkers
coming into starts screaming I love the way
they cut the sound to that's a very common
technique will some of both screens silently
just like it forces you mentally to put your
scream in their mouth she goes down guns blazing
it's a great way to go out if you get a lot
of The Walking Dead you might as well go out
on your own terms on my number two WTF Carol
versus Morgan versus the Wolf I think it went
down a fairly predictable way didn't we all
expect that the end up happening like the
Wolf was going to somehow get the upper hand
and try to escape but I will say hands down
my favorite performance in this episode was
Carol Peletier seriously she is so compelling
I'm in a kill him to keep him from killing
anyone else your Morgan has a good philosophy
to I totally get it but come on dude seriously
this guy is gonna kill everyone every chance
he gets but just put them down let me know
in the comments like did any of you guys agree
with what Morgan was saying like did you buy
his whole sanctity of life thing or would
you have rather let Carol just put them down
but just to be clear no one in that basement
died Carol Morgan even Denise and the Wolf
will be back during the second half of the
season because I'll have to get Denise back
Searcy she said the only medic they have the
gonna have to get her back I thought what
that is is that they'll just give Denise this
big moment will shall have to overcome the
Wolf by herself like this big courageous hero
moment for her she's kind like Eugene where
she doesn't have a lot of self-esteem she
doesn't believe in herself a lot so this might
be the writers creating a challenge for her
to overcome and of course on my very obvious
number one WTF moment Post credit scene Nagin
is introduced on the show verbally at least
your porn underneath the seats given to us
that was my favorite funny line like the minute
I saw those bikers the street I knew it was
going to be knee can but the speech that they
gave was really funny everything you have
the gas in your car the truck itself if you
have porn underneath your seats belongs to
knee can now couple big takeaways one everyone
can stop arguing about how to pronounce his
name Jeffrey Dean Morgan is playing the character
if you didn't know he Sam and Dean staff from
supernatural he's on a bunch of stuff if you
never watch supernatural you probably know
him as the comedian during the watchmen movie
in number two they have skipped a whole bunch
of comic book arcs so right now were at his
around issue 84 in the comic like the tail
end of no way out knee can doesn't show up
till issue 100 which is smack dab in the middle
of volume 17 so that's a way way later it's
well after hilltop and I think that the show
is doing that so will pry be seeing a bunch
of people and characters from volume 15 through
volume 17 the back half of the season so if
you do want to read long in the comic books
just start with volume 15 I guess we also
have to say bonus WTF they they made us wait
till the first commercial break during into
the Badlands to see this Post credit scene
as I saw a lot of people really upset about
that on twitter let me know in the comments
below what you guys think about this episode
in were you mad that they didn't kill as many
people as got killed during this comic book
storyline all things being equal it's not
over till it's over but there are a bunch
of people that survived that did not survive
in the comics what's can happen next is I
will do predictions video for the second half
of the season because we do know that doing
more comic book stuff we know Nagin's coming
so would probably know where were headed next
congratulations to last week's giveaway winner
the turkey you and a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on the
back and my channels and get your contact
info and there is a much a Batman view Superman
got them flash arrow crossover stuff happening
next week so if you're not sure what's going
on just stay tuned you can follow me on twitter
and Facebook for updates on all that stuff
there are links at the bottom the description
for that. Just in case you guys haven't seen
it you can click here for all my walking dead
season six videos and you can click here to
learn all about the Batman v Superman tailer
coming tomorrow night thank you so much for
watching, everybody let's high five! someday
this pain will be useful to us